Film Courage: Writer Elizabeth Renzetti of
Globe and Mail wrote an article recently about
Iggy Pop.
I don’t know if the two of you happen to
read it?
But she basically said that “If Iggy Pop
can’t live off of his art, then what chance
do we all have?”
And I’ll play the part of Elizabeth for
a second.
So she writes “A new reality has tripped
him up and it’s the same one shafting artists
all over the world.
Namely that everyone wants to listen and no
one wants to pay.
So in short, the cat is out of the bag in
the new electronic age with electronic devices
which estrange people from their morals also
make it easy for people to steal music (i.e.
content) then pay for it.
We know this is something that the two of
you have had to deal with.
We want to get your thoughts on it.
Jamin Winans: Do you want me to start?
Kiowa Winans: You did start with a hard question.
Film Courage: [Laughs] No pressure!
Jamin Winans: My feeling is that we’re in
a period of transition more than anything.
I don’t necessarily think that what is going
on right now is the future.
I think things are always changing.
And yeah, I agree that right now it’s particularly
difficult to monetize your art, especially
if you’re trying to do something very independent
and outside of the system.
I guess I feel like a monetized solution is
coming and we’re slowly going to enter into
a period where artists really find their niche
and find out how to survive.
I think right now a lot of people are still
thinking about the hey day of the last 20
years where DVDs and ancillary markets were
like a big thing and the industry as a whole
is still kind of clinging to the money that
they were making on that market and the same
thing with the music industry, it hurts right
now because we’re going through this transition.
Optimistically, I think it’s going to work
its way out.
Kiowa Winans: I think it’s two things.
I think it’s ease of access and the whole
piracy idea or movement has happened out of
a reaction to ease of access and things being
really overpriced.
I think that when I was a teenager, I spent
all my babysitting money on CD’s that cost
$15.00 - $18.00 dollars and I only liked one
song on the album but you’ve just shelled
out $18.00.
Same with the cost of DVD’s and Blue Rays
and people keep trying really hard to keep
locking up territories and making region coded
disks and ultra violet this and this digital
rights management.
And the longer that Hollywood and the record
industries keep trying to push people out
and charge them a lot, the angrier they get
and there has got to be a happy medium at
some point and hopefully there will be, whether
it’s a Bit Torrent bundle with a pay gate
or something that eliminates the barrier of
access and also eliminates the over-priced
nature of what’t happening.
So that is my hope.